let's talk about the media because you
mentioned they can write whatever they
want and i'm just i'm absolutely dying
to cover this because i just
it's about me and you know love myself
uh i tweeted
impeach queen elizabeth this is clearly
not a real
real tweet but uh michael malus i
learned from the best
and i put a bunch of party hat
celebration emojis followed by the
winking meme from wandavision
like can i make it any more obvious you
can't impeach the queen that was the
joke
because they want to impeach trump so
basically what happened was something
happened where the queen was called
racist i guess i have no idea
i don't care about the royal family or
megan markel or whatever it is they're
doing but apparently there's something
about the baby
and then people were complaining about
the queen or something so then i
jokingly put impeach queen elizabeth
jokingly obviously in what what reality
would someone think you i legitimately
thought you could impeach
a monarch if it were that easy we
wouldn't have had a revolution
i vote to impeach king george or
whatever so
here we go ladies and gentlemen let's
talk about no accountability in media
from me from m-e-a-w-w can queen be
impeached call for monarch's removal
after megan and harry's racism claim in
oprah interview
so uh this is just absolutely incredible
let me read this paragraph for you
several people criticized the monarchy
for its ignorant response
which failed to address the actual
issues raised by sussex's
american journalist timothy daniel poole
better known as tim
name oh my god trouble on social media
even went on to call for the impeachment
of the queen he tweeted impeach queen
elizabeth
first of all she's queen elizabeth ii
the other queen queen elizabeth is dead
i'm pretty sure that's out of context
they didn't put all the emojis
that's right they didn't put all the
party hat emojis celebrating
the 35 year old who was also a youtuber
political commentator received support
from people on the social site as one
user wrote
let's call congress into session because
we're the world police right
this this is a journalist like a human
being wrote this
and so some people have pointed out
they're not stupid
they did it on purpose they're trying to
manipulate the people who don't use
social media into genuinely believing
i'm calling
i would love for this to be out of my
wikipedia page just please tim poole has
called for the impeachment
it's here hey newsguard certified source
ladies and gentlemen wow
but as if you could call congress into
session to remove
the british queen it's amazing stuff
they write this stuff without doing any
research let me read a little bit more
they say
another user comment commented then
let's make it happen
before or after her next election asked
a third user
what whoa that's amazing
ladies and gentlemen please share this
segment with your friends and family
to help them understand why the media is
fake news
not all of it not all the time but just
come on so
i'm going to reveal the dark secret i'm
going to i'm going to reveal a very dark
secret my friend
um i was i wasn't going to say anything
about this
but because i've accomplished my goal
already i think it's now fair that i can
reveal
my experiment yeah i i've been saying
for a long time i hate twitter and i
don't want to use it right
and then i thought you know i got 810
000 followers and like there are people
who follow me what what is the upside of
twitter what's the point of using it i
mean you can generate news coverage and
attention for yourself and people are
it's a community they're talking
but for me running a business there is
zero upside it is only a detriment
tweets are taken out of context i'm
accused of things i didn't say or mean
and i'm like
i'll say something that's like you know
i think
the famous joke is i like pancakes you
hate waffles and that's what twitter is
so i decided to do an experiment i call
this anti-tweeting
i tweeted you need to understand the
power of anti-tweeting
journalists don't do research so what
you anti-tweet
is taken as law so anti-tweet stuff and
watch the news world sound like
lunatics the point being instead of
tweeting
actual opinions tweet garbled nonsense
and leftist tribalist talking points to
see what happens
so i've tweeted biden is the most
popular president in american history
i've tweeted biden rule so excited for
his speech just things that i just i
don't care i don't care about twitter
but i have a theory
my theory was news media commentary on
an individual is based off of their
tweets and nothing else
they won't do research and so i had this
idea if i
spend a certain amount of time tweeting
things that are absolutely
counter to my actual personality on this
show because i don't care about twitter
anyway
i'll tweet things like martin is great
party hat celebration i tweeted uh uh uh
when they announced joe biden was gonna
give a speech
i am so excited i have been in anxiety
waiting for this speech to happen
this is going to be amazing biden rules
and i'm like i'm just waiting
i want to see if it'll work because i
genuinely believe it will i got the idea
because i tweeted that the mr potato
head thing was stupid who cares about
the gender of potato
and the independent took my tweet and
claimed i was an outraged conservative
and i just i was what i was making fun
of the people who were making fun of me
i don't care about a potato
so i'm like okay let's play this game
i'll just tweet
garbled nonsense and left tribal talking
points like pro-democrat stuff and see
what happens
and sure enough amazing like only a week
an article pops up saying tim poole
calls for the impeachment of the queen
and i was like
it works it absolutely works so now i'm
just gonna start
like i don't look i don't care if people
follow me or not i hate twitter i think
it's an awful place
i'm just going to either the full-on you
know michael malus is one of the masters
of twitter
he knows how to just tweet things that
you can't decipher yeah
and then it's a reflection of the tribal
individual so if you know when he says
we don't deserve donald trump that's
like the easiest
explanation because you don't know if
it's for or against trump and then
people who assume he's on the right will
say you love trump
on the left we'll be like you're right
we don't deserve this so i'm thinking
like i'll do a series of those things
very ridiculous posts like i gotta be
honest i did put the winking emoji on
the impeach queen elizabeth thing
but i when i typed in impeach queen
elizabeth i was sitting there thinking
for a second i'm like
is this stupid enough to work like it's
a really stupid tweet
you know what i mean like is this gonna
trick any journalist i underestimate it
whatever
i don't care about twitter click and
here we go now we have an article
tim poole calls for the impeachment of
the queen but guess what it's historical
fact now
which means on wikipedia you can add a
section says tim poole called for the
impeachment and removal of queen
elizabeth
and that it's it's certified but here's
the best part
my public statements don't count as a
legitimate source a reliable source
here's the best part m-e-a-w-w
is a newsguard-certified site i don't
know it's considered reliable by
wikipedia
someone could now add to my wikipedia
tim poole called for impeaching the
queen
i can then publicly state to millions of
people on my show
i was screwing with the media because i
thought it was funny and they can't
add my explanation to the wikipedia
because statements from me don't count
but a journalist
claiming i said something does i figure
if i carry on with this anti-tweet
campaign eventually get to a point where
i can easily prove the paradox
because my wikipedia page should end up
being garbled nonsensical gibberish
like tim poole a pro-democrat biden
donator donor who regularly cheers for
donald trump on you know on on you know
on youtube or whatever and it's just
like
make it nonsensical so what'll end up
happening
journalists don't do research but my
public statements don't count as a
reliable source
the more journalists quote tweet me and
the more they say tim poole did
x the more my historical record will
turn into garbled
mangled nonsense and i'm all here for
it'll be hilarious i keep thinking about
the egyptian hieroglyphs and i wonder
how many of them were
the garbled garbled sarcasm i don't know
twitter's a new thing man yeah but
garbled sarcasm isn't
you could be like i'm a pro peace
isolationist who loves that joe biden
just bombs syria
you could say something like that that's
an anti-tweet sort of so what
not necessarily right because if i said
it's it's so great that joe
joe biden bombed syria they'll read that
as sarcasm if i just say
it's it's it's a good anti-tweet would
be i'm proud to have a president who can
make decisive actions
in the middle east this is real
leadership right
so it's like that's not sarcasm i'm just
legit saying something stupid
that i don't actually believe but it's
on twitter
so i can explain right now this is my
favorite part about all of this i
learned this you know because i'm like
i'm watching how wikipedia works and
stuff
i'm watching how i can literally say
in the microphone i i believe universal
health healthcare is something to strive
for it's a challenge to get there but
i'm absolutely in favor of it
not like bernie sanders with abolishing
private health insurance
uh i think social programs are fantastic
and i was a beneficiary of social
programs that helped help me stave off
homelessness but i do think there's
corruption we should we should weed
out i can say as many left-wing policy
positions as possible
i'm pro-choice i'm actually in favor of
diversity in films and movies just not
this woke garbage like i'd actually love
to see
more uh women and people of color as
lead roles in superhero films
and they will keep saying over and over
again it doesn't matter what tim poole
says
he's right wing okay well then i'll go
on twitter and get all the journalists
in the world to say i love biden
and then write whatever you want but the
official sources say tim pool loves joe
biden
and then i'll have all the videos in the
world on my channel where i'm like
biden's trash
so i think it'll be it's it's an
interesting and uh you know you know
what i realized
let me explain too i don't care about
what these journalists say about me
i mean there was a period maybe where i
was like i was worried that they were
gonna try and cause damage to my person
my business my property
and now i'm just like i really don't
part of it's because when you have the
microphone and a tv show of your own it
just doesn't really matter what other
people say because people are coming to
you directly for the source so you can
always talk about that's how rogan's
navigated it throughout the years he's
just like come on guys well
i'll clarify too like deliberate
attempts to destroy my business and to
fame and slander and
and those things absolutely i will
reject resist and if i have to file
court cases right i'm just saying like
when they say insane things about me
like
better opinions tim poole is right wing
and you know whatever and we don't like
him and he's an idiot i'm like okay i
don't care if you insult me i don't care
if you if you don't like my opinions
you can you can say nasty things about
me fine whatever but
i can break the system you know what i
mean i guess you just have to not care
about twitter and i just really don't
yeah not take it too seriously
internet in general and like the way
people feel about you is really
you know as long as you you have access
to communicate with people
that's the key if they i think when
you're when your rights are threatening
you're threatened with prison and like
being
removed from society that's very
dangerous but as long as
you're a free citizen like i used to
tweet my work
i used to tweet links to v2 videos i
used to be a like yours my latest video
and i realized it didn't do anything for
me it just resulted in haters
hating on me tweeting garbage i just
like why am i bothering with this
website
i could put out a tweet it's it's it's
the meme of twitter i could put out a
tweet where i'm like
having a great what did i twist like i
want to get chickens and people like
you're so dumb you're
you're an idiot chickens are stupid
you're stupid and i'm like
what's the point of telling people i
want chickens what is the upside to
being like we're building chicken city
on this show we get critical comments
but most people are like
we're enjoying the content tim enjoy
watching your show twitter is a place
where you can go and yell at somebody
so i'm like all right let's have fun
with it let's just go nuts journalists
take this stuff seriously and they don't
do fact checking or research
all right i'll start saying a bunch of
weird stuff and just see
i got to be honest i didn't realize it
was gonna happen in like three days
you know what i mean yeah three days tim
pool calls for impeaching the queen
that's right well firstly i i agree with
you i think that would be cool if
british parliament rewrote their
constitution
they don't have one peach they're queen
don't have one constitution they should
write one
no they don't have a written take a cue
guys so what happened hey can we talk
about that story for a minute what
happened
uh prince harry and his wife megan
called out the queen for being racist
about the queen um no
royal family garbage yeah we we fought a
war to not have to care about she's like
90 though isn't she
she's abdicating or something okay
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you